okay Bayer the massive pharmaceutical
manufacturer has bailed out on two major
Fox News opinion shows that's me
pretending that there's actually a
significant difference between Fox
opinion and Fox News reporting moments
and programs and hosts Bayer has pulled
advertising from Tucker Carlson's show
and from Laura Ingraham show now both of
these shows you might know have already
had serious advertising issues because
the shows are toxic and Bayer has been a
major advertiser Beier was Tucker's
fifth largest advertiser and Laura
Ingraham second largest advertiser and
the reason for the cancellation is being
reported as white nationalist rhetoric
on Tucker Carlson's show and Laura
Ingraham defending a white supremacist
named Paul Nealon on her program and
interestingly Bayer has actually a
little while ago started reducing and
pulling ads off of these shows now it's
being formally reported based on
contacts with Bayer so what I want to do
here is cut through all of the BS for
you because even within our audience the
the idea of an advertiser boycott is
controversial sometimes when we talk
about advertiser boycotts people will
make so-called free speech arguments
against ad boycotts even though you
can't argue against the reality if that
calling for a boycott is a form of
speech a company deciding where to
advertise using whatever system they
want to use to figure out where to
advertise is a form of speech so there's
this weird thing about criticizing ad
boycotts and demands for ad boycotts on
the basis of free speech because it is a
form of speech in and of itself to say
to a company
please don't advertise on this show
there are sometimes sort of weird
Business Regulation arguments that
people will make against ad boycotts
although I don't even understand those
in this context so I don't even know how
to refute them they just don't make any
sense to me here's the bottom line as I
tweeted yesterday if you don't like the
fact that advertiser boycotts can
negatively impact show
that you watch shows that you listen to
shows that you like if you don't want
advertiser cancellations to be a threat
to programs that you think are good
programs stop making media reliant on ad
dollars what I mean by this is if we
didn't have a system where shows
depended on advertising money then the
ad boycott would lose its place as a
threat to the existence of programming
this is why I've been trying to grow our
direct membership for years I know that
we joke about how much I talk about
membership or whatever every dollar that
we get from membership is a dollar of
what I would call immunity from
advertisers from YouTube D monetization
which we'll talk about later because
that's happening again Facebook D
monetization this couldn't be more
obvious one way or another you are
paying for the show okay you either
watch an ad and pay with your attention
and then the advertiser is the one that
actually makes the financial transfer of
dollars directly or you pay the producer
directly through a membership through a
pledge drive on NPR or PBS through a
cable subscription for some channels if
we had more direct financial support
when YouTube's app at pocalypse hit in
2017 it wouldn't have mattered if our
level of financial support was decimated
from YouTube because we would have that
direct support in the same way we have
advertisers someone could if they wanted
to go to our advertisers and say I won't
support you if you continue to advertise
with David Pakman now I'm guessing most
advertisers would say David Pakman
hasn't said anything discriminatory or
racist or xenophobic we don't know why
we would pull our ads from David Pakman
but that would be a threat that
disappears if our level of direct
financial support goes up the legal side
of this is super clear like I'm not
making a partisan argument advertising
choices are a form of speech period
lobbying companies not to advertise or
to advertise on whatever show is a form
of speech it's protected 100 percent
it's 100 percent fine we can debate
whether an ad boycott is a good strategy
I think it's great when activism has an
impact right in the real world it's
harder and harder for an individual's
voice to matter we know that the the
demands or the desires of rich people
are way more likely to become law or
policy than the demands of poor people
and middle-class people the demands or
the ideas or the the desires of big
corporations are way more likely to be
taken seriously by our elected officials
than those of just your individual Joe
or Sally or whoever so in a world where
it's harder and harder for an individual
to have their voice heard I think it's
great when activism has an impact and it
has had an impact throughout boycotts
but I agree that there is a real problem
when media outlets are so over a barrel
by advertisers and the way to fix that
is support the shows that you like if
you want them to cover what they want to
cover not be threatened by the loss of
ad dollars if they have a membership
program sign up Fox is different number
one they don't actually even really need
to make money because rich right-wingers
fund them they also don't have
membership but when it comes to YouTube
or other platforms I mean we know what
the solution is under one percent of our
audience our members I estimate as I
said on the Joe Rogan show 80 to 85 or
even 90 percent of our audience can
afford two bucks a month if we grow our
support from under one percent of our
audience to three percent any advertiser
that wants to boycott us can boycott us
YouTube can D monetize us it would not
matter and what's most exposed to me by
the controversy of these ad boycotts is
not really the debate over the ad
boycotts themselves my view on that has
been clear for a very long time it's
that we have a problem that advertisers
have so much power and we know how to
fix it direct support of shows let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman if you love learning new things
you probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill share is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video